GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S THREE OH
FIVE AND WE'RE STARTING -- A
HEARING ON AGING AND LONG TERM
CARE -- TODAY IS TUESDAY JULY
NINTH.
AND WE DON'T HAVE BUT WE ONLY
HAVE THREE ITEMS.
AND I EXPECT THEM TO BE VERY
QUICK BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF
THE AUTHORS HERE SO -- WE'RE
WAITING FOR THE OFFICE TO SHOW
UP SO -- OF THE THREE SENATORS.
WHOEVER'S STAFF IS WATCHING
PLEASE.
REMIND THEM.
I KNOW IT'S A BUSY TIME BUT
REMIND THEM TO JOIN US SO THAT
WE CAN QUICKLY GET UNDER WAY
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE
[inaudible]
ANY
.
LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE WE GET A
FIFTEEN MINUTE.
AND A HALF YEARS.
DOWN YEAH -- PATTERSON JERSEY SO.
THERE ARE
--
ONE THE WHOLE
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
BOB.
SO AS WELL WELL WE HAVE FOUR
MEMBERS HERE WHY DON'T WE
ESTABLISH QUORUM.
VERY QUICKLY SO SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
NAZARIAN PRESENT VOEPEL.
MOURNER HARBAUGH.
KALRA.
LACKEY.
RADIUS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RIGHT SO QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED
AND WE CAN VOTE THE FIRST BILL
OUT WHEN A AUTHOR JOINS US.
AGAIN WE HAVE THREE BILLS AND
WHICHEVER AUTHOR.
OF FIRST JOINS US WILL BE ABLE.
TO START THE COMMITTEE RIGHT
AWAY [inaudible]
THE NORMAL [inaudible]
FULL OR MAYBE HEARING ABOUT A
TRICKLE AND STANDING FIVE FEET
DOWN.
YOU KNOW THE COMPANY THAT THE
CREDIT.
NEXT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
IT WAS HER AND SO THE FIRST IS A
VERY.
THE WEATHER SERVICE.
MEMBERS.
AFTER HAVING A LOT.
SO IT COULD BE HARDER.
FOR ME TO USE IT RIGHT UP.
I WAS A
THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
[inaudible]
CONTROL [inaudible]
RIGHT
[inaudible]
YEAH
WE OR
WELCOME SENATOR. TO BE A
GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE THANK YOU.
IT'S GREAT TO BE BACK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE DID ESTABLISH CORN.
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WE GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND
SENATOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SAID HELLO THAT'S ALL
YOU SAID ALL I NEED TO SAY --
WELL.
LET ME JUST THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT SB
SIX ELEVEN WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
HOUSING OLDER PERSONS
EFFECTIVELY OR HOPE TASK FORCE.
AS PART OF THE STATE'S MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING WHAT WE KNOW IS
THAT -- WE HAVE WE FACE A
TSUNAMI OF SENIORS COMING UP IN
THE NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY YEARS.
OF THE DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFT WILL
IMPACT ALL AREAS OF SERVICES --
THE SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY HOUSING.
WE'RE ALL AWARE THAT THE HOW OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN THE STATE
BUT IT'S GOING EVEN IT ACTUALLY
HAS TAKEN A GREATER TOLL ON ARE
OVER SIXTY FIVE POPULATION THE
FASTEST GROWING -- HOMELESS
CATEGORY IS THE OVER SIXTY FIVE
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT PEOPLE
HAVING WORKED SPENT THEIR ENTIRE
LIFE LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
WORKING AND SUPPORTING THE
ECONOMY AND THEN TO END UP
HOMELESS AFTER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE IT'S IT'S PRETTY
HEARTRENDING.
ACCORDING TO THE UCLA CENTER FOR
HEALTH POLICY RESEARCH MORE THAN
HALF OF LOW INCOME OLDER TENANTS
ARE SEVERELY RENT BURDENED
SPENDING MORE THAN 50% OF THEIR
INCOME ON HOUSING.
THE DISPARITY BETWEEN HOUSING
COSTS AND INCOMES IS LEADING TO
A RISE IN HOMELESSNESS AMONG OUR
OLDER ADULTS.
AS POLICYMAKERS DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS TO CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS CRISIS GOING TO
BE.
IMPORTANT THAT WE UNDERSTAND ITS
IMPACT ON OLDER ADULTS.
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
MULTIPLE CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS INCREASED FRAILTY AND
LIMITED MOBILITY AND THE NEED
FOR IN HOME SERVICES TO MEET
THEIR NEEDS AND REALLY THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT IS TO
START. TO TO STUDY AND
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED -- AS WE
LOOK AT THE ALTERNATIVES THAT WE
HAD RIGHT HAVE RIGHT NOW THAT
ARE TOTALLY INADEQUATE.
AS PART OF THE MASTER PLAN PLAN
PROCESS THE HOPE TASK FORCE WILL
CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS FROM AROUND
THE STATE. TO IDENTIFY POLICY TO
HELP OLDER ADULTS AND THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES AGE IN PLACE.
AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO INTEGRATE
THE DELIVERY OF HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES TO PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMES.
AND TO DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES TO
DEVELOP INTER GENERATIONAL
HOUSING THAT INCLUDES SERVICES
AND SUPPORT FOR A MATURE
POPULATION.
SO ABOUT WITH ME AS CASE YOUR
CONNOR FROM THE STATE TREASURER
ON A MAS OFFICE WHO IS A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND MEGAN
ROSE ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE.
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA ALSO A CO
SPONSOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR THIS THOSE.
ENJOYABLE -- DO PASS AND A
SUPPORT SUPPORT FROM BOTH SIDES
AND YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SHARKS THEN I'LL KEEP THIS BRIEF
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE CASE YOUR CAR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR STATE
TREASURER FEE ON A MOCK.
I'LL JUST SAY THIS ISSUE IS
PERSONAL FOR HER SHE'S HAD BOTH
HER PARENTS LIVING WITH HER AND
SHE'S BEEN TAKING CARE OF THEM
HER MOTHER RECENTLY PASSED AWAY
DURING.
HER CAMPAIGN AND WHAT WE FOUND
WAS THE RESOURCES WERE NOT
AVAILABLE OR THERE WAS NO
STREAMLINED FASHION TO FIGURE
OUT WAS ACCESSIBLE.
AND SHE'S ONE OF THE HIGHEST
RANKING MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA SO
IF IT'S HARD FOR HER TO NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM HOW HARD IS IT GOING
TO BE. FOR FOLKS WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES AND CAPABILITIES THAT
WE HAVE AT OUR DISPOSAL SO WE
VERY MUCH INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS WE THANK THE SENATOR AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
FOR WORKING ON A MASTER PLAN.
THAT IS REALLY COMPREHENSIVE WE
SEE HOUSING IS A BIG PART OF THE
PROBLEM THAT WE WANT TO FIX AND
ALTERNATES TIME OVER TO MEGAN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MEGAN
ROSE WITH LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA
WE NEED CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
OVER FOUR HUNDRED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WHO PROVIDE.
HEALTH CARE SOCIAL SERVICES AND
HOUSING TO OUR OLDER ADULTS OVER
A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND OLDER
ADULTS.
AND I THINK THE MAIN THING THAT
I WOULD LOVE FOR ALL OF YOU TO
TAKE AWAY AS IS THIS ISN'T JUST
A BILL ABOUT HOUSING.
I WHEN WE TALK TO OLDER ADULTS
AND HOUSING WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
IT AS PART OF OUR LONG TERM CARE
SYSTEM BECAUSE FOR SENIORS IT
REALLY.
IS A HOUSING IS AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT TO PROVIDING HEALTH
AND LONG TERM CARE TO OUR OLDER
ADULTS AND THIS BILL SEEKS TO
BREAK DOWN THE SILOS THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN ALL OF OUR GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK WITH OUR
OLDER ADULTS.
AND BRING THEM TO THE TABLE HAVE
THEM START COMMUNICATING
TOGETHER SO WE CAN REALLY
MODERNIZE AND MAKE OUR SYSTEMS
MORE NIMBLE AND MORE ADAPTABLE
TO THIS GROWING POPULATION OF
OLDER ADULTS AND THAT CARE AND
SERVICES THAT THEY WILL NEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTATION -- ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
FAMOUS CHAIRMAN KEEP THE ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA PURPOSES ATION
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE SAY WITH THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AMYLIN MATHIS WITH THE U. D. W.
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I CAN'T EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE AREA AGENCY ON AGING SANTA
CRUZ AND SAN BENITO COUNTY.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT ALSO JUST
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A SEPARATE
TASK FORCE TO LOOK AT THIS IT'S
FAR TOO BIG AND TOO COMPLEX OF
AN ISSUE. TO JUST HAVE A FOLD IN
WITH OTHER EFFORT SO WE REALLY
THANK ARE THE AUTHORS OF THE
BILL AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY I WITNESSES AND AGAINST
AGAINST.
NO ANYONE ANYONE MANY SPEAKERS
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MR LACKEY YET JUST
REAL QUICKLY CERTAINLY WE ALL
ARE VERY MUCH AWARE.
OF THE THE AFFORDABILITY OF
HOUSING PROBLEM AND THE SHORTAGE
OF HOUSING AND SO YOU'RE TO BE
COMMENDED FOR BRINGING THIS
LEGISLATION.
HAVE FORCED A TAXI VOTE ON BUT I
DO HAVE A QUESTION I KNOW THAT.
ARE GOVERNOR'S CREATE AT LEAST
FIVE TASK FORCES.
IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS AND WE
JUST LIKE TO KNOW HOW THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTE TO THE
MASTER PLAN.
AND HELD THE FUNDED.
SO IT IT'S DIFFERENT THAN THE
MAT IT'S VERY SPECIFIC ON
HOUSING IN IN IN PARTICULAR
HOUSING AND THE RELATED SERVICES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE NEEDED --
OR SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT HOW
WE CAN ASSIST THE SENIORS TO AGE
IN PLACE.
AND AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT IN A WAY THAT THAT.
ALLOWS INDEPENDENT LIVING WHEN
THEY WANT TO BE INDEPENDENT AND
THEN TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
SERVICES -- COME IN AND PROVIDE
PROVIDE THEM THE ABILITY FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO STAY IN THEIR
OWN HOMES OR TO BE ABLE TO STAY
IN IT KIND OF AN INDEPENDENT
LIVING.
ARRANGEMENT RATHER THAN LIVING
IN.
RATHER THAN BEING FORCED TO LIVE
IN -- ASSISTED LIVING SITUATION
WHICH IS A LOT MORE EXPENSIVE
AND SO THAT THE GOAL HERE IS TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE THE PIECES THAT
WE NEED TO INVEST IN.
AND YEAH I MEAN THAT'S IT SURE I
WOULD UP IF YOU DON'T MIND SOME
OVER I'M HAPPY TO ADD THAT WE
BELIEVE THE TREASURER'S OFFICE
THAT THE MASTER PLAN.
IS AN ITERATIVE PROCESS SO WALL
WE ARE VERY MUCH ON BOARD WITH
THE THE GOVERNOR'S GOALS OF
HAVING A FRAMEWORK ESTABLISHED
BY OCTOBER FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY WE THINK WHEN THE
MEN ARE MASTER PLAN WHEN OUR
TASK FORCE COMES BACK WITH THE
SPECIFIED AGENDA WE'VE GIVEN
THEM TO LOOK AT AGING IN PLACE --
ELDER -- ADULTS ARE LOOKING AT
BECOMING WHOLE ARE ABOUT TO
BECOME HOMELESS OR ALREADY
HOMELESS WE PUT OUT A LIST OF
SPECIFIED OBJECTIVES FOR OUR
TASK FORCE TO ME AND WE BELIEVE
THAT ONCE OUR TASK FORCE COMES
BACK.
THEY CAN BE WORKED INTO THE
GREATER MASTER PLAN BECAUSE A
MASTER PLANS ARE GREAT FRAMEWORK
BUT YOU REALLY NUTS AND BOLTS TO
HOLD IT TOGETHER WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE -- IS PART OF THAT
PROCESS AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE WITH THIS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR FOR
BRINGING THIS -- I THINK THE OUR
STATE TREASURER ALSO WITH A VERY
PERSONAL STORY.
I DO APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE INCORPORATED INTO
THE MASTER PLAN BUT YOU'RE RIGHT
I THINK THAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOUSING AND VERY
SPECIFICALLY THE NEEDS OF
HOUSING OF OUR SENIORS AND THE
DIGNITY -- OF STAYING AT HOME
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE
VERY SPECIFIC TO OUR SENIORS IS
NOT JUST HOMELESSNESS IN GENERAL
IT'S FOR OUR SENIORS SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU YOU HAVE --
PRESENTED THAT.
THIS TO US SO THAT IN THE END
THE THE THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING
DOES HAVE A SPECIFIC INCLUSION
OF THIS SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
GREAT THIS DOESN'T YEAH I
ENJOYED TO PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THE
SENATOR -- YEAR AFTER YEAR WITH
HOMELESS COUNTS WE ALSO SEE THAT
THE FASTEST GROWING SUBSET OF
THE HOMES POPULATION IS AMONG
SENIORS.
AGE SIXTY TWO AND ABOVE AND SO
WHATEVER THE CONFLUENCES ARE
THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING ARE THE
FACTORS THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING --
IT'S A VERY TIMELY AND PERTINENT
ISSUE AND QUITE FRANKLY LONG
OVERDUE SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS -- THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND LET'S OPEN THE ROLE.
SB SIX ELEVEN NAZARIAN HI IS ARE
IN I'D VOEPEL.
I BORDER ROCK.
KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REYES.
REYES AYE.
RUBIO.
RUBIO WHY MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOING IN FILE ORDER MISS RUBIO.
SENATE BILL THREE OH NINE
WELCOME.
SO I'LL BE BRIEF -- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHOI MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TâM PRESENTING SB
THREE ONLINE WHICH WOULD.
REMOVE THE MINIMUM DONATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE'S MUST RACE
IN ORDER TO REMAIN LISTED ON THE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX FORM UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
ALSO KNOWN AS CSL IS THE STATURE
OF STATUTORY AUTHORIZED BY THE
DEDICATED TO ENHANCING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR OLDER.
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
CSO ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS OVER THE
AGE OF FIFTY FIVE TO ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS SHAPING POLICIES THAT
AFFECT THEIR LIVES.
AS YOU ALL HEARD BASED ON THE
PREVIOUS.
BILLS -- THE FIRST THING IS THAT
ARE VERY IMPORTANT POPULATION IT
KEEPS GROWING AND WE DEFINITELY
A KEEPER SENIORS ENGAGE AND
PUTTING OF POLICIES FORWARD THAT
REALLY WORK IN REAL TIME.
AND SO WITH ME TODAY I HAVE --
MISTER JOHN POINTER WHO SERVICE
AT THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
CHAIR FOR THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE ONE ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE START.
ANY COMMENTS THAT IS OUT OF THE
HOLD MY COMMENTS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU FOREST'S MAY
HAPPEN I'LL USE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
TO READ MY COMMENTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT.
PLAY CAMP ONCE AGAIN FROM THE
TRIPLE A SANTA CRUZ AND SAN
BENITO COUNTY SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT.
I THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER WITH MASTER PLAN ON AGING
AND WITH GROWING NEED OF THE
POPULATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S AS MANY ALLIES IN
LEADERS.
THAT WE HAVE -- EITHER BAILABLE
AS POSSIBLE TO MOVE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES FORWARD AND SEE
CELLS CLEARLY ONE OF THOSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OPPOSE ANY OTHER WITH ANY
WITNESSES AGAINST.
ANY SPEAKERS AGAINST.
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU SURE THANK YOU CENTER
FOR BRING THIS FORWARD I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE WORK OF
THE SENIOR LEGISLATURE AND I
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES
SOMETIMES WHEN THERE'S SO MANY
COMPETING MEASURES.
OF GETTING THE THRESHOLD IN SO
HE COULD QUITE SIMPLY JUST DROP
IT OFF OR WE CAN AT LEAST SAYS A
LOOKS LIKE AT LEAST IN RECENT.
OUR RECENT HISTORY HAS BEEN TO
WHO OF THE TENTATIVE.
FUNDED TO TO OUR BUDGET PROCESS
BUT IT DOESN'T HURT THAT
WHATEVER WE GET TO THE VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS HELPED OFFSET.
WHAT WE HAVE TO GET FROM OUR
BUDGET AND THIS PAST YEAR LOOKS
LIKE NINETY ONE THOUSAND WAS THE
MOST -- THAT TO THE FUNDED
GOTTEN THE THE VCF FOR THE
LEGISLATURE GOT AND A WHILE AND
THE REALITY IS LEGISLATURE.
DOES THAT MAKE UP LEGISLATURE
ARE ADVOCATES.
ALL YEAR LONG UP THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND SO I THINK IT'S A IT'S
A PRETTY GOOD USE OF OUR
RESOURCES. TO NOT JUST FUNDED
BUT TO ALSO KEEP IT ON THE TO ON
THE LIST AND SO DOES THAT
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT INTEREST
MAYBE CAN FIND WAYS MARKET A
LITTLE BIT MORE SO THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND -- BUT THEY LOOK AT
THE OPTIONS WITH THE CAN SHOULD
BE TO THAT SPEAK AND BOOST THAT
NUMBER OF NINETY ONE THOUSAND SO
UP CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE MEASURE
AND START EVEN WILL BECAUSE OF
UP TO TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISS REYES.
THANK YOU HI THERE WE HAD THAT
DURING OUR BUDGET SUB ONE WE HAD
A GREAT ADVOCATE.
THAT INSISTED THAT WE PUT SOME
MONEY IN THE BUDGET FOR THIS
PROGRAM ALSO HAS THE SAME LAST
NAME -- AND SHE WAS SUCCESSFUL
IN GETTING THE THE FUNDING IN
THE STATE BUDGET [inaudible]
ONGOING FUNDING.
THANK YOU FOR THE CORRECTION --
ONGOING FUNDING WHICH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BUT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE AN ADVOCATE TO SAY
THAT IT'S NECESSARY IT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN -- I DO HAVE A
QUESTION.
WHY THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR THRESHOLD WHY
WAS THAT PUT IN?
WIND UP THIS CSL ORIGINALLY
STOOD UP [inaudible]
OF AB. THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY
AGNOS IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE DID NOT
ESTABLISH ANY THRESHOLD IN FACT
THE ORIGINAL INTENT WAS.
THAT WE WOULD BE CONTINUOUSLY.
FUNDED REMAINING ON THE TAX
CHECK OFF IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES THERE WAS THE
INTRODUCTION OF A MINIMUM -- IT
WAS PRETTY MUCH ESTABLISHED
ACROSS THE BOARD ARE ROB.
POINT IS THAT.
WE FELT IN DO FEEL THAT WE
SHOULD BE RULED BY WHAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL INTENT.
OF THE LEGISLATION IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WITH THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SIX AND THAT IT WAS INTENDED TO
FIND ADVOCACY EFFORTS OF WHICH
THE ANNUAL SESSION LEGISLATOR
VISITS FROM THAT KIND OF THING --
FALL UNDER HIM THAT WE WE WOULD
REMAIN REGARDLESS.
OF A MINIMUM ON THAT PHONE
INDEFINITELY SOMETHING CHANGED.
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES TO
CHANGE THE THINKING ON THAT WE
DON'T AGREE WITH.
WITH THAT OBVIOUSLY BUT WE
WANTED TO BRING THAT UP TO
REMIND PEOPLE THAT THE RITUAL
INTENT WAS THAT WE HAD NO
MINIMUM REMAINED ON THE FUN
INDEFINITELY.
THANK YOU IN IF I MAY -- MISTER
CHAIR.
IT IS IT A QUESTION OF THE COST
OF MAINTAINING THE FUND OPEN.
IS THAT THE ISSUE DO YOU KNOW OF
I DON'T KNOW BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH.
THE FUNDS FOR THE VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS COME RIGHT OFF THE
TOP.
OUT OF THE EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTEEN
MONIES OKAY SO I'M NOT SURE THAT
WOULD REALLY.
BE -- AN ISSUE -- AND I WOULD BE
SPECULATING IN TERMS OF WHY THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND CAME
INTO WHY THAT.
THRESHOLD WAS ESTABLISHED VERSUS
ANOTHER NUMBER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOWEVER -- YOU'LL
NOTICE THAT THERE WERE OVER
THIRTY FUN ALMOST THIRTY FUNDS
NOW ON THE TAX CHECK OFF AND
SOME OF THOSE ARE MADE IN THE
MINIMUM AND SOME OF THOSE ARE
NOT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR VIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU I KNOW
THAT -- WE MET WAY WAY BEFORE --
WE WERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND I
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK -- THEY'VE BEEN ACTIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY EVEN THOUGH WE
WERE NOT -- LEGISLATORS YET AND
SO WE'VE KNOWN -- OUR OUR SENIOR
LEGISLATORS FOR A LONG TIME AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
FOR YOUR ADVOCACY WORK AND FOR
CONSTANTLY REMINDING US THAT --
YOU ARE THE NEXT BIG POPULATION
AND THAT WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF
YOU BECAUSE TAKING CARE OF YOU
MEANS TAKING CARE OF US I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND THANK YOU.
TO SENATOR RUBIO FOR BRINGING
THIS UP -- I THINK THAT YOU HAVE
NOT JUST HERE -- WITH THE BOTH
SENATOR RUBIO MYSELF BUT I THINK
WITH THAT THE REST OF OUR OF MY
COLLEAGUES WERE ALWAYS
ADVOCATING AND I KNOW THAT WE
DID TAKE ON THAT -- ISSUE AND OF
SOMEONE IN THE CHAIR ONE MAN WAS
WAS AT THE TIME WAS --
INSTRUMENTAL IN MAKING SURE THAT
THAT THE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
I'M GOING OF FINE WAS WAS PUT IN
THERE SO BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY [inaudible]
GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS BILL.
DOES SUPPORT A ED TO PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AS WELL -- WITH THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST WHEN I THINK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ALSO THINK.
A SUPPORTER FOR FOR COMING TO
ADVOCATE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO FEDERAL.
AT MOTION MADE BY MISS RUBIO AND
SECOND BY MISS RACE IF I'M
GETTING IT RIGHT.
SB THREE OH NINE NAZARIAN AYE
NAZARIAN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I BORDER HARD ROCK.
KALRA FIVE KALRA AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REYES.
AS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE THE MEASURE PASSED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
RIGHT LAST BUT NOT LEAST CENTER
HOTEL THOUGH.
WITH THE SENATE BILL FOR THE
THREE WELCOME.
I WILL KEEP IT SHORT THEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH -- MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S AN HONOR
AND PLEASURE TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON -- TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB FOUR FIVE THREE WHICH
WOULD HELP INCREASE OLDER ADULTS
AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES ACCESS TO LONG TERM.
SUPPORT SERVICES THEY NEED -- IT
DOES SO BY SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING AGING
DISABILITY RESOURCE CONNECTION
PROGRAMS.
INCREASING THE QUALITY OF
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE.
AND ENCOURAGING THE EXPANSION OF
EIGHTY R. C. PROGRAMS AND TAKEN
STEPS TOWARDS CALIFORNIA
BECOMING A NO WRONG DOOR STATE.
OF A NO RUN OUR STATE IS A
SYSTEM THAT ENABLES CONSUMERS TO
ACCESS ALL LONG TERM SOCIAL
SERVICES OPTIONS THROUGH AN
AGENCY ORGANIZATION.
COORDINATED WORKER PORTAL IT'S
THROUGH THE A. D. R. C. PROGRAMS
THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE CONNECTED
TO SUPPORT SERVICES NEEDED TO
KEEP THEM SAFELY LEAVING LIVING
IN THEIR HOME -- TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO THESE -- CRITICAL
SERVICES THE EIGHTY RC PROGRAMS
PROVIDE AS BEFORE FIVE THREE
CREATES THE ADR C.
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM --
WHICH WAS -- FUNDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR.
AND THIS PROGRAM ONE SURE THAT
MORE CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES THEY NEED AND TODAY
HAVE VICTORIA JUMP FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK -- I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND
HOW TRUE PARTNERSHIP AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS TRANSFORMING THE
TO THE COMMUNITY AND TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE HI MY 100%
BELIEVE IN THE EIGHTY R. C.
MODEL.
AND THE NO WRONG DOOR MODEL AND
SEE THEM AS A COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTION TO PROVIDING A
COORDINATED SYSTEM OF
INFORMATION AND ACCESS FOR ALL
PERSONS SEEKING LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
I'VE BEEN THE DIRECTOR OF INTER
COUNTY AREA AGENCY ON AGING
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR AND
I KNEW OF THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
RESOURCE CENTER IN OUR COUNTY.
THE PROVIDE SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES BUT REALLY
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY DID --
OUR INTERACTIONS WERE VERY
LIMITED WE SAW EACH OTHER
OCCASIONALLY EVERYTHING WAS VERY
STYLE LOADWE DIDN'T SHARE ANY
CLIENTS IF YOU HAD AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY WENT TO
THEM.
IF YOU NEEDED MEALS OR IN HOME
SERVICES YOU WENT TO ME -- AND
REALLY THIS MODEL PLAYS OUT
DAILY IN MOST COUNTIES IT IS
VERY STYLISH.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT TOO MANY
PEOPLE WERE COMING THROUGH OUR
DOORS AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN
TO TAKE UP A LOT OF TIME --
BECAUSE THEY NEVER GOT WHAT THEY
NEEDED THE FIRST TIME THEY CAME
TO US.
I'M WITH THE UNPRECEDENTED
GROWTH IN THE POPULATION WE KNEW
THAT WE HAD TO DO BETTER FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
SO IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING RESOURCE
CENTER DIRECTOR AND I SAT DOWN
TO DISCUSS WITH A PARTNERSHIP
WOULD LOOK LIKE -- AND WE
APPLIED FOR DESIGNATION WITH THE
STATE -- AND NOW HAVE A SEAMLESS
PARTNERSHIP WHICH TRULY IN NO
WRONG DOOR MODEL I'M AN OLDER
SHARE WE KNOW ONE STORY ABOUT
THE MAGIC OF THE PARTNERSHIP AND
WHAT IT REALLY LOOKS LIKE AND
HOW IT WORKS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WE HAVE A SOCIAL WORKER WITH OUR
AREA AGENCY ON AGING THAT'S
EMBEDDED IN PUBLIC HOUSING THAT
WORKS WITH PEOPLE OF ALL AGES
THAT ARE HIGHER RISK OF
INFECTION -- BECAUSE OF
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES AND OTHER
FACTORS SO IF YOU LIVE IN PUBLIC
HOUSING YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW THE
RULES.
IF YOU DON'T THEN YOU KNOW YOUR
CHANCES OF BEING EVICTED ARE
VERY HIGH SO WE HAVE A SOCIAL
WORKER THERE TO PREVENT IT.
SO ONE DAY WE RECEIVED A
REFERRAL FOR A WOMAN THAT ALL
COLD JONES -- AND HER TEENAGE
SON BILLY SHE HAD RECEIVED A
THREE DAY OF ACTION NOTICE FOR
PUBLIC HOUSING.
BECAUSE OUR SON BILLY WAS OUT OF
CONTROL IT HAD SET A FIRE IN THE
BUILDING -- IT WAS FURTHER
DISCOVER THE BILLION ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE MULTIPLE TIMES AND WAS
THREATENING TO KILL HIMSELF
AGAIN SO PUBLIC HOUSING THREE
DAYS WE'RE GOING TO GO.
LIMITED OPTIONS -- HE ALSO
STOPPED GOING TO SCHOOL AS WELL
SOURCE SOCIAL WORKER CALLED IN
THE ASSISTANCE FROM THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING RESOURCE
CENTER BECAUSE WE ARE AN EIGHTY
OR SEE WE HAVE THAT PARTNERSHIP
AND WE KNOW WHAT EACH OTHER DOES.
SO WE WERE ABLE TO CALL IN THEIR
TEAM AND COME UP WITH A PLAN TO
PREVENT THE EVICTION AND GET THE
FAMILY.
THE HELP THAT THEY NEEDED -- A
HOMELESS MENTALLY ILL MOM WITH A
SUICIDAL TEENAGE SON WOULD HAVE
BEEN A TERRIBLE OUTCOME WHICH WE
WANTED TO AVOID.
SO THEY WORKED WITH BILLY WE
WORK WITH JOAN WELL THE
INDEPENDENTLY LIVING RESOURCE
CENTER WORKED WITH BILLY.
IN ADDITION TO HIM NOT GOING TO
SCHOOL IT WAS DISCOVERED THAT HE
ACTUALLY HAD AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY AND WASN'T CONNECTED
TO ANY OF THE SERVICES SO THESE
PEOPLE ARE NOT MEMBERS OF OR ANY
OF OUR SYSTEM SO THESE ARE NEW
PEOPLE TO US FOR WHATEVER REASON --
IT HAPPENS.
EVENTUALLY BE DID CONNECT HIM
WITH SERVICES WORKING TOGETHER
HE WENT BACK TO SCHOOL THE
FAMILY GOT THE HELP THAT THEY
NEEDED.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO KEEP THEM IN
PUBLIC HOUSING AND PREVENT THE
ACTUAL ADDICTION THIS WOULD NOT
HAVE HAPPENED.
YOU KNOW FIVE SIX SEVEN YEARS
AGO IN MY COUNTY THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN EVICTED AND WHO KNOWS WHAT
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED TO THE
FAMILY -- SO NEED IS NEAT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT PEOPLE'S NEEDS
ARE GOING TO BE WHEN THEY COME
TO US.
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR
SYSTEM IS IN PLACE WERE SOME
COULD COME INTO THE SYSTEM
MULTIPLE WAYS.
THROUGH A HOUSING COORDINATOR
THROUGH AN INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE LINE.
UP AND BE CONNECTED QUICKLY AND
SEAMLESSLY TO WHAT PEOPLE NEED
WHEN THEY NEED IT AND I BELIEVE
THAT AB R. C. AS PART OF THAT
SYSTEM.
AND SO I ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GREAT ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
PER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI CAM TRIPLE LIVE SANTA CRUZ
AND SEMINOLE COUNTIES IN SUPPORT
I I ALSO SOMEONE TO SHARE THOSE
BOTH AS BOTH A PERSON OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY AND SOMEONE WITH A
PHYSICAL DISABILITY.
THIS IS A LONG TIME COMING IT'S
GREAT TO SEE THE STATE START TO
TAKE A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN A
MODEL THAT THE FEDS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO PROMOTE FOR A WHILE TO
SOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANY SPEAKERS OR
WITNESSES AGAINST.
WITH THAT ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR IS.
FIRST I WANT TO CONGRATULATE
PLAY COUNSELING WAS A RECOGNIZE
AS OF SMALL BUSINESS OF THE YEAR
IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
CONGRATULATIONS.
NOW.
OKAY CLICK COUNSELING WAS THANK.
I THOUGHT YOU SAID PLAY
COUNSELING.
THE CONCEPT OF NO WRONG DOOR IS
JUST THE BEST THING NOT ONLY FOR
FOR OUR SENIORS HERE AND THOSE
WITH DISABILITIES BUT FAR FOSTER
YOUTH FOR HOMELESS.
WE'VE WITH THIS IS A CONCEPT I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO CREATE FOR
ALL OF OUR SERVICES SO THAT
WHOEVER HOUSING NEEDS THEY KNOW
THAT WHEREVER THEY START.
THEY WILL BE DIRECTED TO THE
RIGHT PLACE I'M SO GLAD.
THAT YOU'RE DOING THIS HERE IN
THIS INSTANCE I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE NO WRONG DOOR THERE'S NO
WRONG DOOR MODEL.
IN SO MANY OTHER SERVICES THAT
WE PROVIDE THANK YOU.
AT GOVERNMENT THERE SHOULDN'T BE
A WRONG DOOR.
THE CATTLE SYSTEM.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT YES --
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
GREAT WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF I THINK YOU SEE THAT
THE GOVERNOR ALSO FELT THAT YOUR
ISSUE WAS VERY IMPORTANT AND AND
WAS.
AND HIS HELP WITH HIS FINANCING.
YOU DO ENJOY A DO PASS TO
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
SO MOTION AND A SECOND BY MISS
RACE AND RUBIO.
WE OPENED A ROLL -- I'M SORRY
BEFORE THAT WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER.
SB FOUR FIVE THREE NAZARIAN AYE
NAZARIAN AYE VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL
AYE BORN HARD ROCK.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REYES AYE REYES AYE
RUBIO AYE.
RUBIO AYE THE MEASURE PASSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU --
AT THIS POINT.
WE'RE DONE WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE
COMMITTEE OPEN FOR A FEW MINUTES
UNTIL -- SOME OF THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WHO ARE MAKING
PRESENTATIONS IN OTHER
COMMITTEES HAVE A CHANCE TO COME
IN AND ADD ON THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SORRY
.
NOW THEY'RE JUST GIVING YOUR
AND
THE OR DOES IT.
IN MY FIRST [inaudible]
THE
SEE THESE --
YOU CAN READ.
OUR YOUR